♪
'S BEFORTHFEDS OUT WITH A
SCARY WARNING  HOW INTENTIAL
ATTACKON THE POWER GRID COULD
PLGE AMERICA INTCOMPTE
DANESS.
IT COMES DS AFGUNFIRE INTO
SUBSTIONIN NORTH COLIN
SHUT OFF LHTS FOR THOUNDS
FREENG TEMPERATURE BY E
WAY.
BUT THFEDSORN IT WAS N
ISOLED INCIDENT.
GET THIS FIVE ELECTRITY
SUBSTIONS IN OREGON AND
SHINGTON ATTACLASTONTH.
NORTH CAROLI GOVNOR SAYS
EY SHOULD BE AATIOL ISSUE.
WE HAVE TO HA A SERIONATIAL COT
PROTECTINGUR CRITICAINFRASTRTURS
LONG.IT WAS CLEAR TY KNEW H TOCE
APPEARANCE BORE ROLD, WE
VE BEEN WOIED FOR NY YEARSABOUTD
THEUSSIANS TANG DOWN OU
GRID SOMEH.
TURNS T ACTUALLY AMECANS
HEREWE TNK AMERICANS
SHOOTING UP THSUBSTATIONS.
ANTEDATEHE SRIFF SAIDWHOEVESHOTT
RANDOMBUTHEY KNEW EXTLY
AT THEY RE DOING AND
TARGETED IT TO TAKE OUT TH
ELECTRICIT
>> Harold: IEATHAT ALSO.IT LED D
THIS NEW ECTLYHAT THEY WERE
DOG.
SSIEND I AS MUCH AWEIKE
SHOOT BB GUNS,  WOULDN'T
KNOWHAT  SHOOT AT IF WE RE
SHOONG TING TO PUT OUTHE
LIGHTI SYSTEM.
DON'T GO AROU SHOING
BB GUNS IN TOWN.
BUT THIS IS WHAT THE
INSTIGATIVE POWE OF NGRESS
IN THIS AND AT SULD BE A
ONE  THE THINGS THEY SHOULD BE
CUSEON.
I MEAN, WHAT IS ITEING DONE IN
NEW YORK A MEMISHERE I'M
FROM AND DALLAAND HOUSTON ANDET.
W MA PEOPLE DO THEY INK
THEYNOW WHAT TO SHT ATND
AT TO GRAB AND WHATO PL
OFF  YOUERE GOING TO P
OUT IFOU A TINTO DISRUPT
LI THIS POWER GRID?
WE SO WHAT HAPNED  TEX
WITH T WEAER A LITTLE OV A
YEARGO.
WHATER MONEY MAY BE LEFT IN
THE FRASUCTURE BILL PAEDBY CONGE
SOME OF THOSE SOURS AND ME
THE UNUSED RESOURS FOR
COVITO TRYO HELP CITS AND
MUCIPALITIES DEAWITHHISISSUE BEE
SPITS BEFORE WE VE
IMINALS, JUDGE
SSO FAR COME I HAVEN'T SEEN
ANYTHING, MERA LIGHTS TH
WOULD LL US WHO THESPEOP
ARE.
AND  COULD LEAD  SOMETHING
LI A HICIDE BECAUSE
SOMEBODY DS --
>> Jeanine: COURSE BUT THE
HOMICI, THWITH RESPECT T
LEASA BIT.
HAVE 5,000 POWER ATIONS,
BSTATIONS IN TS COUNTRY.
ALL OF THEM E ACCESSIBLE.
OK?
SOME OTHEM HAVE CAMES AND
ME CCRETE BARRIERSSOME LIKTHE LI
DID  SHOWS FROTHEY WE A
COLE OYEARS AGO.
EY HAVE CHAILINK FENCESAROU THEE
CALL TO MI SICON VALLEY NI
YEARAGO EY SAID SOMEONE TH
A OTGUNIGHT OUT DRINNG
SHOW UP A SUBSTATI BUTHEYWERE WE
CAMERAS.
GET OVERHE CCRETE BARRIER.THIS E
AMERIC GRID.
THAMERICAN GRIIS A
VULCANIZED STEM OFRIDS THAT
ISYPICAL OF THE THIRD RLD
COUNTRY.
THE IS NO ONE AGCY TT
TUALLY REGULAT ALLF IT.
I WT YOU TO THINK ABOUT
TH STATE H AGREED, THATSTATE HA.
AND CAUSE OF ALL OTHESE
ELTRIC COMPANIESAVE
LOBBST, NO ONE WANTS TO BRG
THGRIDS UPO PA.
E PROBLEM IS T WAYHIS CAN
HAPPEN IS  CANELECTROMAGNETIHOLC
BE AUCLEAR WEAPON  AIGH
ALTIDE.
IT COULD BE CYR, IT ULD
VIBLE LIKEOU TALKED ABOUOR
CANE THE SO EVERY 1
YES, TRE IS AN ATTK IN
THE SUCREATES KIND OA
NUCLEAR SOLAR ARE.
SO IN THEND, WE COULD SE
ERYTNG, BANK ACCOUS,
HOSPITALS.
WE CLD BIN DARKNESS INHE
NORTASTE -- THIS IS A MESS!
>> Harold: AGREE.
Dana: WHAT ARE WE GOINGODO, GR.
I S JUST THIING WHAT IF I
NTEDO KILL JESSE WATTE?
WHAT IF THIS WAS A HE PLAN T
KILL O PERN HERE AND SO,
LES Y JESSE LIVES  LIKE
PLAIIELDNEW JERSEY.
I GOLE BECAUSE IT IS GGLE,
THE STATIO THAT ARE THAT EASY
TO FIND.
FIGU OUT WHAT STATION TERS
TOOUR NEIGHBORHO.
SHOOTHAT OUT.
U HAVEO ALARM SYST.
YOHAVE NO SURVEIANCE
CARAS.
IS PERFECT STORM R ME TO
NALLY ACHIEVE  DRE OF
MURDERING JEE WAERS.
DOT THK -- I MEAN, THE
STIONS ARE SITTI DUCKS.
I'M HESITA TO EN TALK ABOUT
THE VUERABILITY THAT IS THE
BEUSE THE CURI HAS N
BEEN UPDAT IN CADES.
ABE WILL DO THIS SEGNT JESSE
MPLAINS HE LT THKEYSN
HIS MASERATI ON THND
SEVEH AVUE.
YOU ACTUALLY A GIVG PEOPLE
INRMATION THAT YOU DON'T WT
GIV
MARATI'S IN FRONT OF THE&M
STORE  CASE YOU ARE
NTIONG.
>> Jesse: I SHLD MTION
WHAT YOU D AHARO'S HOUSE.
>> Gg: IT IS EASTO LOCE
THE SUBSTIONS.
AND SO, WHAT IT DO IIS
ALMOSTQUIVALENT OF A TERROST
ORRIMINAL OWINTHE PIN
MBER TO OUR ELECIC GD.
THAT IS HOW PORTT -- IT ISTHE P.
ITS EASY.
HAPNED, THEY HAVET.
THINWE HAVE  REALI A
CHAILINK FENCES ARNOT ENOUGH
OR HING EM OUT IN FIELD
ISN'T ENOUGH YOU HAVE LONG RAN F
CAN DO IT.
NEED BETTER MONITING D
REINESPOSTURING CASE THIS
HAPPENS.
>> Dan WHAT YOU INK,
JEE?
>> Jesse: A BUNCOF SABOTRS
RAYEWITH FIRIN SAN JOSE
2013.WE DID SOME DIGGG ANFOUND
OUIF YOU WERE ATCKED JUS
NE SPEFIC BSTATIONS, YOU
CAN BLACUT THE EIRE COUNTRY.
D HAVEOU EVER EN LING IN
THE SUBURBS,ND FOR A
NERATOR, BACK  LIGING
CANDS, TT  HOW SCARY IT
.
THATOULD ACTUALLY LL ME.
YOU WANT TO KNOW AUT THEINFRASTH
SSED, $1.2 TRIION?
HOW CH OTHE MONEY WANTS TO
UPDA THE GRI
ANDAVE EY SPENT ANY OF
TH?
NOWHAT DO TH SPE THE MONEY
ON SO FAR?
THEY ARE IN THPROCESS OF
BUILDIN ANTIRACIST
BIRDWATCHINGOOTBDGE IN
PHOENIX AND THEY ARE UNDWAY
WI INSLLING HEATED SEWAL
IN A SLL TN INNEW HAMPIRE.
SO-
>> Greg: MFEET ARE CD,
JESS
>>esseLET'S TAKE TIME WITHTHE GS
BETTERELT E SNOW.
>> Harold:T IS HARD TO DOBECAUS.
THIS IS STEWIDE AND THE
FEDERAL.
Jesse: SPT $65 BIION.
>> Jeanine: RELY QUICKLYWENT TOR
SAN JOSE A THEY HAD L OF THE
CEERS THERE.
YOU OW WHAT THE ISSUWAS,HOWAS TA
"T WALL STREET JRNAL" WHO
WROTE THE ARTICLE AT TALKED
ABT TANG DN THE GRID.
THEYIDN'T CA ABO
REGULATI IT CAUSE EVERYBOD
GE LOBIST.